[Music]
hello hello hello hello
hello
what's up david ramirez how's it going
what up
hey here we go max conrad what's up
random elaine oh no hold on who are the
first people
kenny i shot david ramirez elaine barr
burn random midnight max
what is up everybody are we ready for
some one division
not you siri how on earth could you
possibly think i was talking to you siri
all right so do we find out
who the engineer is in this episode
also how is the sound can you hear me
all right
let me check my phone just to make sure
everything's going all right
looks like everything's all right cool
all right oof
i uh
man i i'm wondering if if tonight's the
night where we find out who the engineer
is
um and i wonder if we're going to be
overwhelmed or underwhelmed because
it could easily be sorry let me turn
this down so there's no echo
because it could easily be somebody like
talos's daughter
which i think that might be a little bit
underwhelming
um not that her character won't be good
but i think it might be a little bit
underwhelming because everybody's
expecting like reed richards or hank
mccoy but
i think probably blue marvel
is where they're going with this um
it just makes the most sense because
blue marvel had a relationship
with monochrome in the comics now he
wasn't exactly an aerospace engineer but
you know it's dmc
they can kind of do what they want
i'm trying to see i did a poll today on
youtube
i wonder if let me see who everybody
thinks it is
let's take a look at this poll
i can't look at it take a look
hey i'm doing good david bennett how are
you doing thanks for the super chat
um tahin sinha thanks for the super chat
also how are you david hope you're doing
well we're ready for some one division
um tohen what if it is blue marvel i i
think it might be
in all honesty i'm checking my poll
right now that i did today
um let's see 62 percent
think that it's mr fantastic ree richard
12
think it's blue marvel 19
thank hank mccoy and seven percent
thank other slash commented down below
um one person lance edsel
alizarez said it might be the kid from
iron man 3 harley keener
that would be very interesting it would
be very very very very
very very interesting um
make sure i don't miss any super chats
here yeah sweet um
that would be like a like a cool full
circle type of thing
um for sure if it was harley keener from
iron man 3.
i don't know if the connection would be
there
um i think it's
probably blue marble
just to tell you guys um if it's reed
richards
i asked myself if i would be
happy with that introduction
or would i like the fantastic four
teased
in like a post-credits scene i think
i think either way i am going to be
happy but you know the question would be
am i going to be
am i going to be happier with
with something else is really my
question hey max
conrad thank you so much for donation
won't be able to join your lives next
week
in the week after i have school maybe i
can send a super chat ah
that's a bummer but hey no problem
school is very important and thank you
for the super chat
thank you for the super chat i've been
seeing you comment on my my normal
videos i hope you've been
been getting my replies we got five
minutes
i am doing well who who was that sorry
the chat moves so fast
uh harrison harrison harrison
i am doing well yes thank you
um
hmm i can't think of like many other
people that i think the aerospace
engineer would be
i mean if you think about it there's a
lot of people
um and we did get a
hey forsaken hunter what's going on
blue wrench
um i don't think i can do that from here
in all honesty yeah
i'm not sure how i would do that
did i just do it i don't know man uh
i'll have to figure that out off
dm me on twitter i'll have to figure
that out off screen
all right
did i just see
but uh you know marvel showed us that um
what are they calling them they're not
caught on promos
i didn't think they're calling them
featurettes anymore but marvel shows
like that behind the scenes uh
uh if you only caught a featurette
and you could see um
who might wonder man in the background
hey lone wolf thanks so much for the
super chat woof woof um
i mean it's all speculation at this
point it could be reed richards but
it could be blue marvel hank mccoy what
about fantastic four do you think they
could cross over and set up a new movie
oh for sure dj gaming and thank you so
much for that super chat
um and hunter thank you for that other
super chat as well forsaken
um yeah no it could it could be the
fantastic four
i just don't know if i'd be happier with
a bigger introduction hey thanks david
bennett thanks for the
the 2000 super chat um yeah i just don't
know if i would
i don't know i question how to to it's
one thing like
how to bring somebody in and then it's
another thing um
uh to bring somebody in and then
to hint at them right
uh no
harm hey thank you for the super chat
can you go more into detail on the
backstory of the engineer
uh once they say who the engineer is yes
hassan hinks gamora aerospace engineer
i'm not thinking so that would be hard
to pull off
trevza what's up thanks for the super
chat do you think vision's memory will
be reset again
i don't think vision's making it out
alive
okay samuel williams i do have a discord
server
um go to the about me in my
my youtube page preston dingus thanks so
much for the super chat
appreciate it we have two minutes two
minutes
get your disney pluses ready to go
get it on get ready to hit that play
button
all right if i
missed any super chat i don't believe i
did but if i did i deeply apologize
i just went through them threw them on i
believe i got it but we have one minute
to one division
it's mephisto preston i hope
hey brianna rihanna hanover thanks so
much for the super chat
and good evening to you as well i hope
you're doing better i know one of the
comments you made before
um i was wondering about you
so i hope you're doing all right all
right
one minute probably like 30 seconds also
get your play button ready to
press um for those of you who can't
watch it i will show the screen
sometimes
but unfortunately i am not going to be
able to
put it on my screen because i would get
a copy strike notice
and we don't want that
okay let's see
[Music]
probably got a few seconds left
preston dingus thinks it's mephisto and
i would love for that to happen
all right everybody get ready to press
play
oh my one division just freaked out on
me
i think it does this every time
oh thank you lula lila v i'm so sorry if
i
didn't pronounce that right thank you so
much
and thank you for the super chat okay i
have episode seven and it's called
breaking the fourth wall 38 minutes long
previously on one division
here we go
i hit play go
[Music]
so they're just recapping what we saw
last time
it's not like your dead husband can die
twice
i'm i'm excited to see who hayward is
um thanks for the super chat forsaken
i don't know yes but i don't think they
could survive outside of the barrier
um tayonna paris who plays monica rambo
said that
it's gonna be epic and sad i believe was
the quote um
and something about it being very sad so
we'll see but all right let's roll in
the marvel logo
all right here we go
this is the clip that we saw this
morning from good morning america right
now
we've all been there
intentionally expanding the borders of
the false world you created
if yours isn't working just keep
refreshing because mine's working
we're watching it right now just keep
refreshing just keep refreshing
i've had to do it before too
hey john adkins coulson lives
yeah if he showed up wouldn't be
surprised at all
i just kind of expect that thanks for
super chat i appreciate that and i'm
with you on that
quarantine style staycation
this is mountain dew before anybody asks
she's still in the what was it a
sokovian fortune teller
costume in bed all right
oh it was wii controllers that they had
i thought it was switch
i'm a dummy dum dum
she just grabbed some milk
sugar snaps
that's funny sugar snaps
missing there's a missing children's
sign on the milk
hmm
huh
here we go here's the one division intro
oh my gosh it's just like the office
oh my god
oh that's so
cool oh and that's like modern family
oh that's so awesome so we're temporary
retreat
eight miles outside of west view all
right oh
we're watching it y'all so y'all need to
start it on your disney
plus
oh hello vision
interesting
uh it's working for me guys look there's
darcy
mumbo jazzy what's up man remember jazz
i'm sorry i've never noticed i never
know if that's supposed to be an ir1 but
uh
i don't think he is either thanks for
the super chat
[Laughter]
laughs
oh
um
real rejects you guys what are you doing
greg
she said vision is made of vibranium the
twins literally inherited
tough skin
agnes is here
[Laughter]
oh guys this episode might get intense
oh no
[Laughter]
oh
it's working for me guys
so agnes is taking the kids
oh no so agnes has the kids
finally we're seeing this scene
they teased this in the first trailer
oh that's interesting
wow
oh sweet hunter yeah it looks like it's
working for some people and not for some
just keep refreshing guys
codename counteract
i knew it
yes he does those totally right i was
totally right i won't spoil it for
people but i was right
oh wait hold on is this the engineer
i might not be able to hold this one in
so i'm going to say who the engineer is
so
oh no wait is this the or is this
sword
i'm not sure who this is
[Music]
is that the person
i'm a little confused
oh
um
i'm like
is it digressing or progressing
eric morgan server crashed
for disney plus
i'm still watching it
well who said it oh my gosh oh another
weird commercial
i'm still watching it guys
it's a weird commercial
hmm
huh that's clever
the twins are with agnes right now
what the heck is i don't know it's
i wonder if we're gonna get any answers
this episode
she just mentioned ralph again
monica just said it's our last shot
jimmy and she's going in
all right it's about to get intense
um
yeah we need to get some answers but
this thing that she's driving that we
saw in the trailer so it's not a spoiler
but the thing that we saw in the trailer
is pretty cool looking
three two
one
dang
oh
oh snap okay no that ain't gonna work
oh snap oh
oh
oh
oh snap
well okay
oh snap
oh snap oh snap
oh wow oh there she is
oh
and there it is wow
clip's coming clip's coming
there she is photon
she has powers
look at that look at that
mambo thanks for the super chat looks
like vision couldn't get out because
wanda
she met
yeah it makes sense makes sense mumbo i
agree with that
oh
laughs
oh interesting
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
they keep like looking at the camera
just like the office
just like oh man
oh jarvis
just said ultron again
oh that's pretty deep
um
so darcy just had a talk with vision
and oh monica's got her freaking
accurate costume
oh snap i think something's about to go
down
oh snap
oh snap
oh she's got powers
oh
oh snap
oh
stuff's about to go down
so
oh what are we about to find out
oh
do something oh my gosh that was intense
but nothing happened
looks like agatha harkness
is uh responsible for all this
this is something i've been saying
before the episode came out
huh
oh yeah
this episode's got some comedy to it
all right so check this out
agnes and wanda right now it's about to
get intense
and monica was chasing them so it's
about to go down
i think monica's about to burst in oh
wait wait
the kids are gone
oh snap oh snap oh snap i'll snap oh
snap
oh snap
juana's noticing that her kids aren't
there and they were with agnes
she just asked where the twins are
guys it's about to go down her twin her
twins are gone
she said they're in the basement now
she's going down to the basement
what is about to happen what is about to
happen
what is about to happen
oh oh oh oh oh oh
this is intense
no way i'm gonna show the screen
spoilers coming
you should turn away now look at this
it's like a full witch's layer
of like a full witch's layer inside of
inside of
agnes house she is agatha
oh the dark hole book
oh snap
she is agatha oh
oh
i free
look at this agatha all along
look at that holy crap
i knew it oh i knew it
no
oh
dude all right i'm gonna show spoilers
real quick all right
spoilers real quick
spoilers are coming holy crap look at
this hold on
why aren't you working so agatha reveals
herself
to wanda
agatha was controlling her the whole
time
look at that wow all right
all right let's get uh
wow
what's that rc blue thank you credit
scene
there's a post credit scene
oh there is a post credit scene
okay we're gonna post credit scene this
time
whoa
wow was i right about everything hold up
[Music]
all right let's get in the zoom chat
with uh
with my other two dudes what the heck
that was insane
okay that was that was something that
was something
wow
[Music]
that was crazy
what the heck wow
wow
guys
wow
i watched the credits guys i like there
is there is a credit scene for this one
well hey it's on hanks thanks for the
donation super chat appreciate it
wow oh my gosh guys
they did such a good job
hey matt hutch thanks for the super chat
yeah i watched the post credit yeah yeah
they uh
how did they do such a good job
oh my gosh and they showed
the dark hole
dude i oh my gosh okay so
i was kind of right about a lot
hello you know what i'm gonna say right
that we were right over here
i'm telling you that that 100 is strange
i'm calling it now
bro brad we called it since the freaking
beginning of the damn show
i'm clipping that i'm bringing the clip
that is 100 strange she's she hasn't in
the cage she's stroking up like she's
owning him dude owning him a thousand
percent
bro agatha harkness welcome dude
they did such a good job at trying to
convince us she
wasn't agatha harkness they did such a
good job
but i mean we knew it was her right i
mean
wow bro like just the look she gave
when she she just kind of like looked
outside
just the look she gave when she looked
outside and she saw maka with wanda
yeah that's when i knew she was gonna
freaking reveal herself yeah
bradley jones thank you from super chat
do you think jimmy wu will contact
doctor strange
i mean if doctor strange is uh mr scrap
i don't think so senior scratching we've
been caught in this
yeah dr strange
said you're scratchy damn
oh my gosh yeah mambo you might be right
uh guys and look we
we said this like evan peters
he was not quicksilver no
no no he's not
yeah yeah i know
you know mambo thanks for the super chat
you might be right i don't know if the
the hex will give people mutant
i don't know if it will awaken their
mutant powers because it looked like
monica had to go through like three
times to get them activated
uh one shot thanks for super chat feels
like it was predictable
took the easy way out be lying if i said
i didn't see
this coming yeah i mean i it was still
good but this is what i
freaking thought the whole entire time
is what we talked about forever
the people um the show know that that
they knew
us as fans we would have figured that
agatha or
agnes aguilar right right made the show
but it was just such a great way to kind
of
set up these final two episodes yeah
again no more games no more acts
it's game time yeah so agnes is here
she took the freaking boys i talked to
you earlier
poke the boys did i
she's still teasing ralph too yeah ralph
is still
yeah i i do think there's a nightmare or
mephisto there
or you know they may not call him that
but it that's who it is right
like it's a combination of those two
people um
now is i just got a question is evan
peters there to help or harm rainbow i
think it's our harm rambo yeah yeah
yeah he's working for i don't know if um
i don't i don't i think he's like an
actual person right
actually i don't know what do you guys
think i think he's just like literally a
creation
do you think she created him
created him because if we look back to
that episode you know wanda says that
like
like when he knocks on the door she
tells me she's like that okay that
wasn't me
that's what i'm talking about oh my gosh
they did such a good job when
you know what i mean like making you
think like one is lying it is her or
it's her and she doesn't know it's her
right because that was a big thing that
we talked about right brad
and supes like we're like her
subconscious is like doing things
and then and that made us think like
okay maybe it is maybe because you know
i thought like okay the scarlet witch is
in her maybe that's a different
person like doing the ropes and all that
right maybe there's wanda but then maybe
there's a scarlet witch but no it's
agatha the whole freaking time
and like even though we knew agnes was
always we always found the agnes
yeah we underestimated how much she was
really manipulating
oh right oh dude and what did we call
last episode
agatha was faking it in the car yes
right do it she killed the dog
can we talk about how we didn't find out
who the freaking aerospace engineer
dude i know so
it was it well that was the biggest
episode but it
i wanted to see it i wanted to see it i
was like okay here we go
it's getting started when one had threw
her out of the house again yeah it was
like oh it's going down right now
yeah but we know next episode next
episode is the
this is our home so i don't
yeah i don't know a vision so i think it
was one of you two said it
like a few episodes ago i think
that like in that scene where vision's
flying there's like an
explosion in the background or something
and that it might be like
i don't think juan and vision are on the
same side when they're talking about
this i think
you know i mean i don't know maybe she's
talking to agatha saying this is our
home and then
vision's saying like maybe talking to
monica like let's fight for it or
something like that
because well because it's clear like
right now that agatha
is controlling wanda like we even saw
her you know
controller at the end there so is she
fully in control
well here's my thing with that at the
end i think that was
her way of showing wanda that she was in
control the whole time
gotcha i think she showed wanda what we
watched
which was oh oh gotcha gotcha
that's what i took is because it was
very similar to how wanda and age of
ultron
right yeah that was it was the exact
same thing
so that to me like when i saw the
freaking bunny
[ __ ] after this girl we watched the live
replay of this watch party
dude i still have money and i was like
i've been talking about that for a long
time
and uh yeah that's a great one
yeah that's awesome that's 100
yeah it has to be elijah bell thanks for
the super
[Music]
the commercial was linked to wanda being
a nexus being in the comics an anchor or
keystone of the multiverse ah
that's pretty cool i like that thanks
for the super chat
santana bison the layer that book looked
like one of the forbidden texts from the
library of kamar taj might have been
stolen that's definitely the dark hold
that book is 100 the dark hold um which
you've been talking about for a while i
know i have at least uh
it looks like uh looks like
i think a lot of the things we
originally thought before the series
came out are actually how it's going
yeah because just like you know story
wise and all the characters all it just
makes sense
i also think next episode uh her showing
that she's behind everything i also
think she's going to show
how this whole thing started oh yeah for
sure
for sure oh so okay okay
so zechariah tolson thanks for the super
chat you mentioned
dottie right so we haven't seen dottie
but the actress tweeted that she's gonna
come back so
agnes agatha and dottie is arcana
how dare she kill how dare she kill
sparky she's a top-tier mcu villain
i know right john wick is pleased
oh man um
so okay guys are the twins gone
um dude i know but i what i think
because they didn't show us
again if the twins are actually dead
they would have showed us that on screen
because that would have pulled all of
the emotional strings and
they would have given us that scene of
one that literally watching your kids
die
like they would have shown us that if
the kids are actually dead yeah dude
what i think is actually happening
i think she sent the kids to the big guy
mephisto right right again this has all
been about
this has all been for the children so i
think she probably
she completed the mission she she did
her part in getting mephisto the kids
now is when she can have fun and that's
exactly what she turned
yeah she delivered those kids yeah
true mama thanks for the super chat six
hours hope nine is an hour and a half
i think eight eight maybe the next two
will be an hour and a half i don't know
so much for you know the last three
episodes being an hour each
honestly i was talking to matt about
this the other day i was like hey if
they want to
slowly get bigger yeah yeah
i'm all cool with that yeah me too yeah
being like an hour 30 or something like
that
yeah like once again they they just cut
it
right at the end again we're like oh my
gosh like
they're so good at wanting us to want
more and
it's just boys credit scenes
i know now we're gonna post credit
scenes yeah
my chat was saying it too yeah it was my
chat that's like oh it's great i post
credit like
what no is it read no
and then i saw one comment he's back and
i was like
strange
man yeah there's oh my gosh
dude this is one of my favorite episodes
honestly way better than last episode in
my opinion
well the huge reveal yeah last episode
was
good but i think it was one of the like
lower tier ones this episode was great
for me
that was the biggest tease of all time
so phase of depth what did you think of
post credit i think it was awesome
taylor thanks for the donut taylor novak
thanks for super chat
when i saw monica arrive i thought bass
i was like dude there's multiple people
here
yeah multiple bogeys incoming we're
gonna see the whole family
we're gonna see them all the whole
fantastic yeah right they're all there
oh my gosh
did i just see this random army soldier
just
walk up to monica captain marvel symbol
on her hat
so maybe she's the guy maybe she's the
scroll
daughter tells his daughter in disguise
then
i like that right because that's that
was a big guess
for a lot of people it's alice's
daughter
daniel buerta
hope you guys enjoyed that episode that
was a great episode what a wild one
daniel puerto thanks for super chat i
love i think darcy was the highlight of
the episode love how she punched out the
muscle man and vision and her scenes are
amazing
for real her a few things bro yeah dude
and this is why marvel's so good like
marvel studios specifically well marvel
in general but marvel studios in these
castings like because these characters
like i don't want to call them side
characters because i enjoy them just as
much
but like they're so good they're so like
darcy is amazing
jimmy wu is amazing like it's all so
good oh
man but that was the biggest tease with
that
engineer bro
the big thing for me was like tiana
paris saying like
oh i can't wait to see the fans
reactions to the aerospace engineer so
that means we're
gonna figure it out those are her words
right so i mean
here's my thing though wu and the camp
saw her
go in right right so now on the outside
they're gonna be like we have to save or
we have to go in so the first thing
they're going to do is probably call the
aerospace engineer to figure out another
way to get in
yeah and be like hey it didn't work you
know like
yeah jojo burger thanks so much for that
super chat oh my god boys
go to 2822 there's a goat head with
horns
on on agnes's wall in the dungeon
my fisto is coming
bro it's gotta be
also this
so this is like this is
in new jersey right so clearly
this is like from the salem witch trials
right
that happened there because this looks
like it's been there a while granted
she's magic and she can kind of like do
whatever she wants but
this looks like it's been there for a
while somehow she got wanda there
you know i'm with brad i think they
reveal all this
uh maybe next episode for sure dave
they're also saying like in the
background i'm trying to kind of
get it yeah it's like there's something
there though daily cruise family
vacation thanks for super chat anyone
gonna discuss the mail
slash delivery man reaper yeah
uh i think the mailman definitely
probably is uh
the way he that he would give him a
couple shots that were kind of weird
right yeah very specific shots that were
that were weird yeah
um what am i looking for at 40 28 40.
dude
i see i have it right here dude i don't
even know what it is to be honest it has
wings though
and it's like right this is like passing
it
2840 on the bottom right okay hey hey
retweet my latest uh tweet you'll laugh
trust me
oh my gosh
let's see let's see wait it looks like
uh
dang it i can't see it
uh snapped away thanks for the super
chat how is quicksilver alive if agnes
isn't controlling i don't think it's
quicksilver
guys what is that what right
right it's like an angel or yeah i don't
know what it
it is like just wings yeah on the book
no yeah it's like
in the background down the hall like the
pink there's a statue there
oh i see it yeah i can't figure that
looks like a a
duck or a vulture of some kind it looks
like a human to me with its arms up
hmm it's warren that's who it is and
then when i say that i mean it's uh
angel the x-men
um did you see the missing kid
i just almost spit yes i wonder that was
super foreshadowing
oh yeah that was like that was common
like with the 50s
oh for sure yeah missing people would be
put on the back of this
milk yeah and then you know 10 minutes
later
agnes let me take the kids
i was like they're gone yeah i was like
they're gone they're gone
they're gone but dude oh my gosh okay
so like who
who the heck is the engineer i'm kind of
pissed but in like a good way
yeah i'm pissed in a good way in a good
way i don't think they would seize it
that hard and for tiana pierce to say
i can't wait to see your reactions to
the aerospace engineer
that soldier that she talked to wasn't
an aerospace engineer no
no that was she was like she delivered
the goods
exactly so like whoever designed that
technology
well didn't she say in the last episode
that
she was going to meet her guy my guy is
going to meet us in
20 or whatever she's there
uh catboy thanks for super chat i'm
wondering the same wondering where the
kids are gone
um they said that she was quiet inside
yo but boys i mean one thing i'm super
hyped for we're done with this whole
sitcom bs
yeah yeah it it's over it's
it's it's full on marvel now it's
full-on
and oh man okay wait guys okay so here's
here's a question
because this didn't really go the way
that i thought this would go as far as
multiverse is concerned so
what do we think in multiverse now
because i think at this point the
multiverse hasn't really
been opened boys boys hold up i'm sorry
to cut you off
28 44 on the wall there's this there's
like a statue on the left
dude that is freaking mephisto
oh yeah yeah there's a
there's like uh yeah
no i think we could officially say it
oh man guys if it's mephisto
i'm going through every one of our live
streams and clipping every single time
we've said it
i'm doing like i'm gonna give a montage
about the times
i do wonder catboy where the where the
twins have gone i
uh i do wonder if they are if they're
coming back
another thing we gotta talk about what's
hayward launching
they we saw him for one scene in this
episode and he said they were launching
something what the hell are they
launching
i mean yeah i thought about that too i
think it's probably a sentient weapon
and maybe um so
okay so here's like
they we know they have something in
space um
so i wonder if it's something from space
maybe they're bailing
oh you think like they're launching away
i mean i i don't know i'm just throwing
something out there yeah
uh shimmery is small military people do
have engineer jobs in other professions
oh yeah totally totally
i just don't think that that particular
person was the
engineer yeah
right and it wasn't like a big reveal
and tiona paris was like
you know you're gonna be i'm excited for
y'all to see who it was and like
that that we just didn't get anything
revealed so
yo some people are saying where's reid
richards
guys we still haven't seen this we
haven't seen the engineer yet yeah
peter hansen thanks for the super chat
there's an after credit scene yeah i saw
it with uh with quicksilver
and uh i
it's not quicksilver right and the
reason he can move like quicksilvers
because agnes
is controlling him or made him herself
um right so she gave him those powers
it's clear you know we've been talking
about this for such a long time
agatha is like she's so old she's like
thousands of years old
right so she's an extremely powerful
witch
like extremely powerful witch who could
probably
do almost anything she wants like if
we're talking about like power levels of
the people in the mcu she's probably at
the top
like that very well could be doctor
strange locked up in that cage like
easy yeah typing stuff thanks for super
chat what if the thing that hayward is
launching
is mason's daughter in the comics
can you further explain that for me
please
um bradley jones think of super chat hey
where does ultron
could be he could be i mean legit i was
thinking i thought about ultron
immediately when jimmy said
he was trying to bring vision back to
life in some form
yeah oh that was us but uh
when it comes to quicksilver man next
episode
like if we're we're getting action next
episode for sure
yeah for sure i think we're gonna see
agnes continue to use quicksilver now
that they showed him the post credit
scene
and like we're gonna see him fight right
some people man and we're gonna get some
slow-mo scenes
bro monica is ready to scrap bro yeah
one of my favorite characters she looked
really cool
she looked really cool yeah
she looked insanely cool um she was
going through that
when she was going through the hex bro
he kept on hearing captain marvel more
captain marvel boys i think she's
showing up
i still think she's showing up she might
sergey stepping off it has to be fqs
because they have the same power
what's up qs am i y'all know what that
is i'm missing something
no i don't know oh fox quicksilver
um yeah because they have the same power
i i i think that i think agnes is just
giving him that power i i don't think he
actually has it
once again she created him to create
trauma and grief
right right that's why she gave him the
same abilities yeah
and for sure there was something behind
the scenes because like
there's no reason they shouldn't have
brought back aaron taylor johnson right
if this is the case right yeah and that
and that's why it makes sense
uh well i guess this was still like kind
of a weird move by marvel
that i'm not perfectly fine with but it
was still kind of a weird move by marvel
um i think the commercial was based off
the reality stone juan rosales thanks
for
the super chat what do you guys think of
that that commercial
um they just go deeper into character
development for wanda that's what i
think too
yeah daniel puerta maybe evan peters is
mephisto i
i think he is um
i know i don't think so well we're gonna
see him
because i think evan peters is literally
just one not one this agatha's puppet
like yeah so
the gamer thinks of a super chat said
that he saw a chair in agnes's house
that
could have been a wheelchair could have
been something related to professor x
uh maybe i'll have to skip i'll have to
skim through and and figure that out
um dude
the stork came back oh so
hi hi m dirks why do you believe that dr
strange is the bunny so we've been
we've been talking about this for like
some time now um
take it away
[Laughter]
[Music]
and we just all of subscribe all three
of us theorized we did
what if doctor strange was that funny
and agnes is literally just like kind of
like just like
making fun of him she's toying with her
power
yeah i think her dominance over dr
strange by making him this buddy that's
trapped in his cage
and you know what if i was her and i was
thousands of years old and extremely
powerful and i get this new sorcerer
supreme you know
master mystic guards that's like oh
you've been like toying with magic for
two years
let me show you how it's really done
like
like oh you're going to help wanda no
you're not like
i said the series literally spit out his
drink
yeah yeah yeah quest thanks for the
donation
appreciate that it's just and again
it makes sense yeah i'm sorry say what
you want
doctor strange would show up when this
all went down he would know
he would know he would definitely know
he would know
oh that's a that's a great question uh
gaddy
tbh thanks for the the super chat real
question is who is the missing person
yeah um sergey stepping up
if agnes created him why not create
other powers because she's trying to
like bring wanda grief
so she created a different version of
him
um but remember he was like oh i'm the
same i'm your brother bro
blah blah so she's just trying to cause
him grief abolishing super chat do you
think wanda is strong enough to defeat
agatha
no but i think she will have help from
monica and i think
that engineer comes in and uh
yeah uh jojo burger simon williams
wonder man
it's his mind plate yeah
a def i definitely think so because we
saw that promo for wonder man so doesn't
he
unless marvel's like giving us a huge
misdirect he
kind of like has to come in doesn't he
i think the last two episodes are going
to be absolutely just
crazy yeah dude with the way they're
setting it up because like
i mean we we talked about this multiple
times like we're going to say hey j
xylo thanks for the super chat who is
missing person i don't know
man i don't know i'm so confused on that
in all honesty
and we've talked about seeing them
across these three episodes but
at this point dude i wouldn't i would be
surprised if like this just all goes
down in the final episode
yeah man i don't know
i don't know man but hey boys i have to
uh head out i gotta early morning i'm
speaking
uh all right
now summit 10 a.m pst if you uh
if you want to pop by it's free go check
out the boy
i am driving back to utah tomorrow so
unfortunately i won't be there
all right be safe man i appreciate you
both
love back see you guys
wow soups it's
yeah it's getting there man oh man
it's been crazy it has been crazy this
whole journey from the beginning
yeah wow
but anyways guys i'm going to cap the
live stream there thank you guys for
tuning in
episode 4
live watch party us me warren
brad we will all be back here for
episode eight so make sure to subscribe
hit that button we will be back on my
channel
we're gonna be back here for episode
eight and it's only gonna get crazier
from here on out so yeah thanks for
watching we love you guys 3 000
and we'll see you guys next time see you
guys
see you soon all right guys i need to
acknowledge some super chats
don't worry i've not forgotten ah i'm
just trying to get my screen back up now
sorry
all right let's see yeah the stork i saw
the stork i called that from the
beginning it was agatha
um sorry i just want to make sure i
didn't miss any of these super chats
why can't i find them okay wachesky
i have a thanks for the super chat i
have a theory the book the show
downstairs it is the darkhold book for
sure
100 percent gaddy 2bh the missing person
is evan maybe he's ralph and every time
i come mention
him he scares one including yeah i think
definitely a nightmare component for
sure
what's with the fly on the curtain in
agusta's house i think it's just like a
horror movie thing
um and shane martin photo thanks for the
donation i think it's like a horror
movie thing you know how that kind of
happens
matt hutch thanks for the donation
hayward wants to recreate ultron
stop another thanks thanos attack yeah
nah
i i agree i think he wants to recreate
ultron
um
yeah he's totally trying to recreate
hold on
saji johnson it's all the infinity
stones monica space one reality vision
mine agatha power dr schein mephisto
sol dude i really like that that's a
that's a really awesome that's a really
awesome theory
pirate man thanks for the donut could
have sworn that mailman was the missing
person in witness protection
maybe i'll have to re
i you know i always re-watch this right
after i get off the chat i rewatch it
um once just to kind of like
enjoy it again and look for little
details and then i watch it like i go
frame by frame
um let me just scroll through guys and
make sure i didn't
i if i missed super chats i'm really
really sorry
um
i'm trying i wish there was like a
better way
for all of this to uh
for all this to be kind of controlled
but uh james james thanks for the donut
single moisturizer happened in 1962
which were over 300 years ago sorry i
kept saying thousands but i meant
hundreds
file elijah bell thank you files are
linked to demonic forces usually
oh flies are linked to demonic forces
usually gotcha
i'll take note of that um
christopher quinones they were faces of
the devil ig on the pillars yes i saw
that
yes when agnes introduces yeah yeah yeah
i'm definitely thinking
it's uh yeah doom thank you so much for
the super chat
i think the commercial is development
for her being a nexus character
but also i noticed the narration talks
about taking the pill to awaken your
reality
the pill is red matrix confirmed
that's pretty good dude that gave me a
good laugh i like that
uh i think the kids are the bunny and
the fly i noticed when she realized
those kids weren't there
they showed them to immediately that
could be true
um yeah totally
i'm not sure i think that because i
think i think they might be more like
demonic things but
i think the kids are like with mephisto
now antonio
anthony thanks so much for the super
chat
just want to make sure that miss any
theory of the books yeah it's the dark
cold for sure
albert gutto do you think vision would
be triggered because agatha's twins
hostage is also wanda and thank you for
that super chat
yeah i think he would especially that he
knows now that like wanda went through
all this trauma
and and like she had to kill him twice
and i think when she knows that it i
think once vision knows it wasn't
actually wanda doing all of this
he'll be good uh thanks for that super
chat
and tony anthony did you see the
in-credit scene got here late yes i did
but thank you very much for the super
chat and
uh telling me about that i did um
simon williams is an engineer yeah
um and let me
i thought it might be adam brasher he's
not exactly an engineer i think he's
like a
physicist um
but again marvel did that promo
right and uh wonder man was on like the
left side
in the premo you could like see and we
haven't seen wonder man yet so again
unless it's like the biggest misdirect
you could
like give you know what i mean like he's
got to show up eventually
the office intro either meta for john
kasich hinting at reed richards
also yeah the infinity stone abilities
have all been shown
yeah i mean that's kind of funny and it
would
be something marvel would do to like go
that meta for
john krasinski joshuida thanks for the
thanks for the super chat that i think
that would be funny
jamie reed thank you for the donation
hulu girl
figurine on darcy's dashboard just like
daisies from asians of shield
hey they mentioned the darkhold maybe
they'll bring back yeah maybe
i would like to see some people cross
over i really would
stephen jones thanks for the super chat
3 43 turn captions on you
got it let's get these captions on
343 is that the milk scene that
everyone's been telling me about
did i miss something
not a thing weighing heavily on your
conscience
i hope your little ghost arrived home
safe last night
interesting
it's always such a treat to see those
creepy kiddos out in about once a year
later on we'll hear some tips on how to
resist the temptation of all the
leftover candy
interesting or just eat it all
wow
a lot to dissect in this one um
but man was i happy
with this episode um
like really i i was i'm so glad it's
agatha i i think i would have been
pretty disappointed
if she wasn't i got the hardness i think
there have been clear signs
um and i pointed them out from the
beginning i think most of you guys know
i don't need you know
i need to repeat myself or anything like
that but
i think i think it's agatha and i think
it's mephisto
i just think it does uh jessie garcia
thank you so much for the super chat
not you siri did monica unlock commute
in gene or did the hex
wall give her powers also the missing
person agnes husband and what happened
in
f4 theory well you know we did regards
to the f4 theory they didn't reveal who
the engineer was
um because according to tayo and paris
who plays monica and bow it's supposed
to be a big reveal and they didn't
reveal it
so we'll see i still think it might be
read um
the missing person could be as somebody
pointed out
excuse me evan peters um you know she
could be controlling him it's clear that
she is controlling him i don't know if
she created him
or um or if she's controlling him as a
missing person who knows
but i think we will find out as far as
monica unlocking her mutant gene
i don't know if she unlocked her mutant
gene or if it just changed her my this
episode might have changed my opinion on
that i'll i'll do a video on that though
did you notice how agatha was holding
senior scratchy like her cat ebony
spoine uh
thanks for the super chat yes
and we haven't seen ebony yet
um perhaps we will now the black cat um
i still think that you know maybe that's
doctor strange like we were talking
about
infinity shades thank you so much for
the super chat do you think that if they
go
the mephisto route they'll introduce
ghost writers since the two yes
a hundred percent if they don't they're
missing out
or they miss an opportunity uh but
they're smart right it's marvel
they're smart i don't think
i don't think uh you know marvel's gonna
have a problem with that
could have sworn that the mailman was
the missing person
maybe
oh sorry guys i just looked at my phone
it's like super delayed
like i'm having like like it's like
super delayed
um so if you're answering if you're
asking questions and donating and stuff
and i'm getting there just like way
after you
i super apologize about that oh man um
so oh sorry i missed some super chats
don't want to miss them here
i think senior scratch exactly agnes son
nicholas scratch
yeah that makes a lot of sense um
it makes a lot of sense you know what
something that's confusing is i got the
isn't exactly bad in the comics i mean
she
she literally watches franklin richards
you know the daughter of uh
reed richards and sue storm and she
helps want to develop her powers
so i wonder what they'll bring into play
maybe maybe nicholas will come into play
tj lewis thinks the super chat with
marvel becoming more inclusive do you
think that it's possible that agatha's
main villain
know mel melo need it and just girl v
girl
uh a hundred percent that could totally
be the case um
and they might go that route
with mephisto nightmare whoever still
being in the background but
that's not like the villain of one
division per se
it's the villain of like the mcu's phase
four phase five right is so
messed up number could be the next big
villain
that is going to kind of be teased like
thanos was teased during infinity saga
right
so agnes could be the main villain of
one division
mephisto could be in the background
could be responsible for her just like
thanos was responsible for loki right so
yes
i do you think that could be the case uh
ricky reyes thanks for the super chat
cereal box says energy
to 4k cal 12 seems a bit above average
just a little bit doesn't it
marvel's so good at doing that stuff you
know what i mean
that's interesting i'll i'll have to
think about what that means
pisa one i hope i pronounced that right
thanks for the super chat
do you think darcy or mailman could be
dr strange
or if the bunny is strange who are those
characters think
do i think well darcy is darcy um
the mailman could
be the missing person as like some
people were saying
um but so i also think that wanda
or wanda i'm sorry agatha like with her
magic has
just she can control anybody and she can
like
look through people so maybe it's just
her looking through the eyes of somebody
else
um but i think they will reveal that
uh judge of burger can't forget simon's
brother grim reaper yes and they have
teased him right we got that
uh his helmet in the second episode
i still think the brooch that she wears
i still think it looks like
um a scythe it looked like the bridge
she wears it so thank that so yeah we
can't forget about the grim reaper thank
you for that super chat
christian martinez thank you for the
super chat what if pietro is from
another universe but it's mind
controlled by wanda
and he gets snapped up by out of it by
vision
you know i want to say that anything is
possible at this point um
i i'm not actually thinking it's
quicksilver patria i think
agatha made him say that i don't think
he's
quicksilver i don't think he's patreon i
think he's maybe an innocent person or
somebody that agatha created
see lopez four minutes 17 seconds fairy
quit let her spell out an intro
i know what you are doing wanda
interesting
oh yeah i see that and that was
it's kind of cool uh office that's
really funny
dan sinha thank you for the fall for the
super chat missing person isn't revealed
who's that engineer who's a real villain
fists or nightmares i booked a dart hold
this question
book is 100 darkhold take that question
off the table
um missing person not sure who's an
engineer that didn't reveal
real valen mephisto or nightmare
probably a combination of both
that i don't think we'll see in one
division in all honesty i think we're
going to see him i think he's going to
be a big bad
and he's going to show up later squirtle
master kenobi
love that name epic i think evan peters
is a mephisto in disguise thank you for
that super chat and i agree
um definitely andrew s thanks for super
chat this episode is awesome honestly
didn't think agatha was controlling
people from the time but apparently she
is
also what what was that book she had
that book she had is the dark hold
and it's made by um an ancient evil bean
um chathan i believe um
and it plays a big part
in the magical side concerning doctor
strange and agatha
now there's there's spells in there that
you can learn
that are like super op super like you
know like forbidden spells
um and clearly that you know agatha's
the perfect person to have that book
because you know she's out of the
harkness she's been
alive for a very long time she's a very
powerful witch
evan saucedo thank you so much for the
super chat both the mailman and daddy
were suspiciously aware
it almost seemed like they gave agnes a
nudge to stare out the window to see
juan and monica
yeah mate you know daddy is somebody
right and she's
i think she's gonna come back because
you're right um
her and mailman are suspiciously aware
so i'm like wondering
again if agatha has like just minions
she's created and she kind of like
you know as people monitor things for
her or if they're
actual people with her i'm not sure
it will be revealed eduardo thank you so
much for the
super chat hey warren do you think
agatha harness is working alongside
master pandemonium monarch tv producer
kidnapped the twins in the comics
i haven't thought of that until now but
you know what that does make sense
considering the sitcoms and all that
stuff
you've given me something to think about
now thank you for that eduardo huh
well dang well all right guys um
it's 3 18 a.m it's much earlier or later
whatever you want to say it is for some
other people um i have to rewatch this a
couple of times
i have to do my breakdown and i have to
kind of wrap my head around
and get my uh brain what i think is
going on huge episode
huge episode they finally revealed those
agatha
and i'm so glad they did because people
were really starting to question if it
was agatha and i'm sitting there like
yes it has to be agatha
agnes agatha harkness like i was like
it has to be so
um dang
anyways super fun night guys um i love
these watch parties so super great
because i actually get to like talk to
you guys and connect with you guys
um thank you so much for everyone who
showed up tonight thank you for all the
super chats whoever super chatted
um subscribe if you want more marvel
content i'm gonna do a breakdown
of one division episode seven it should
be out in a few hours depending on
you know how much i dive into um and
i've been diving into a lot so
great night great episode um
big reveal i'm excited for the next two
episodes because this was big
but paul bettany talked about a lot of
action and cgi being used we haven't
seen that yet
so home oh my gosh like this is gonna be
insane
so thanks for everybody showed up
tonight um expect my video to be out
maybe like three or four hours uh
we'll see but um yeah this was super
super awesome so all right guys thanks
you thank you so much to everybody who
joined tonight
as always this is super fun i appreciate
and love you all